Okay. Let's now get into this idea, uh, of
the narrative that the Trumpists have been
crafting around the impeachment inquiry and
how it's been going so far and allegations
of illegal secrecy and stuff behind closed
doors warranting Republican's barging in on
a hearing. We're going to go through all of
it. And in fact this week we've been doing
a lot of media analysis exposing how propaganda
cycles work, about how those propaganda cycles
are often self reinforcing like a feedback
loop. And there are a lot of examples recently
that are really good ones at some of the examples
that have been sillier. So earlier this week
we talked about how Fox news covered up the
fact that Donald Trump was booed at the world
series by a crowd that was chanting lock him
up incessantly at Donald Trump. Less important
but still a good example of how the propaganda
cycle works.
But there is a really serious example that
we have to talk about that's taking place,
which is not about Trump getting booed and
his safe space being pierced. This is an example
which potentially could be the difference
maker between Donald Trump being reelected
compared to Donald Trump being removed from
office. Okay. That I, that that is how big
the stakes are with this example that I'm
going to talk about today and it relates to
the constitutionality and the appropriateness
of the impeachment inquiry against Donald
Trump because the impeachment inquiry is getting
more and more popular and because it is being
formalized as soon potentially as tomorrow
by the house of representatives. As I told
you, you're seeing Donald Trump and his followers
and his uh, staffers becoming more and more
desperate in their attacks against the inquiry
itself and their attempt has been to make
the impeachment inquiry appear to be a completely
extra judicial unconstitutional.
Witch-hunt they've said there's no due process.
Well it's just an inquiry and the resolution
that was just released outlines due process,
due process comes during the actual impeachment.
If it were to happen, it comes once. There
is a formal resolution starting an inquiry
with public witnesses, so on and so forth.
They've said only Democrats are involved in
this inquiry. They're keeping Republicans
out. Well, remember number one, the impeachment
inquiry formally speaking hasn't yet started,
but more importantly after those Republicans
stormed a meeting demanding access, we learned
that many of those same Republicans are already
on committees that are participating in the
inquiry and have been questioning witnesses
and allowed to review documents. It was a
total farce. The latest one which I want to
deal with today is the idea that because things
are happening behind closed doors, something
wrong is happening. Some major injustice is
taking place. The truth is plainly available
and one person who happens to be telling the
truth may be shockingly particularly since
Shepard Smith has already departed Fox news
and he was often, his guest is a former judge
and current Fox news legal analyst, Andrew
Nepal Platano who explained, hold on a second.
The impeachment inquiry hearings going on
behind closed doors are taking place consistent
with the rules of the U S house of representatives
and he is correct. Let's look at the video
and then discuss it.
The judge Andrew Nepal town. So let me tell
you what I did for you. Kill me. I read the
house rules and as frustrating as it may be,
to have these hearings going on behind closed
doors, the hearings over which Congressman
Schiff is presiding, they are consistent with
the rules. They can make any approvals they
want. Well, they can't change the rules. They
follow the rules. And when were the rules
written last in January of 2015 and who signed
them? John Bainer and who enacted them? A
Republican majority.
Now before we get into the analysis, did you
notice what Fox clown Brian kill me did there?
When Andrew Nepal Caetano says they're following
the rules, the Fox clown says they can make
whatever rules they want. And Andrew and a
politician who doesn't get them get let them
get away with it. He says, no, no, no. That's
not the point. They being Democrats didn't
make the rules. Republicans made these rules.
These rules were signed into law by a Republican,
a a majority, and it is Democrats now who
are following those rules. I like how Nepal
a Tano does not let Fox clown Brian killing
me. He'd get away with it. But let's now get
to the facts. What we get to is something
I said earlier this week. If you do these
interviews in public possible future witnesses
can watch the testimony and then repeat the
same thing in order to appear as though they
are corroborating testimony and it can potentially
distort the investigation. And Nepal [inaudible]
goes on to also this issue of due process
by explaining these aren't the impeachment
hearings. Those would be public. These are
private hearings to figure out who should
even participate in the impeachment hearing.
Secret evidence doesn't work in this world.
So eventually there will be a public presentation
of this at which lawyers for the president
can cross examine these people and challenge
them. This is like presenting a case to a
grand jury, which has never done in a, in
public. So I get it. The Republicans are frustrated
and they wanted to make a point and they made
their point. They might've made it, but, but
this is just the not the most effective way
to show a respect for what your colleagues
are doing.
I hope that you have good people in the audience
understand what's going on here. Donald Trump
wants you to think that they are impeaching
him in secret, behind closed doors without
due process, for unknown reasons, on the basis
of testimony that will never be made public.
That's not happening. Okay. What they are
doing is what police do when two people might
have committed a crime together. You separate
the people. You ask them questions separately
to see if they're are in consistencies. You
asked them to recount what happened without
having the privilege of seeing what their
potential co-conspirator is saying. Eventually,
once the police figure out the case in a trial,
they might question both of those suspects
in public as part of the trial. They might
question one of them. They might question
none of them. This is a a choice that law
enforcement gets to make.
This is like criminal interviewing one Oh
one and Donald Trump is counting on you not
knowing that. And realistically, even if you
know it, a lot of Donald Trump's supporters
don't know it and it's working because, uh,
among his supporters, there is this contingent
of the belief Trump, no matter what he says,
crowd that has fallen for this idea that there
is something unconstitutional going on, that
there is something extra judicial going on
that Donald Trump has been in some way denied
due process. None of it's true. None of that
is going on here. What's happening is not
even remotely unusual. Don't fall for it.
Don't fall for it. Let me know what you think.
I'm on Twitter at D Pacman. The show is on
Twitter at David Pakman show and coming up
very soon this week. Don't know exactly when,
but soon, maybe tonight. Live stream, live
streams or back on Twitch at twitch.tv/david
Pakman. Make sure you're following me there.
Make sure you subscribe with Twitch prime.
If you are an Amazon prime member, quick break
back after this